mais pour démarrer vous avez peut-être
aperçu quelques deux courbées dans les
rangs de vignes ce matin c'est le top
départ des vendanges en Touraine et oui
c'est le cas notamment dans le
Vouvrillon tout s'est accéléré ces
derniers jours avec ses fortes chaleurs
qui ont permis aux raisins de maturer et
voilà les vendangeurs à pieds d'oeuvre
pendant au moins deux semaines Clémence
d'os qui est Pierre Alexandre Gez ce
sont rendus h1c
première coupe à la main au domaine
cathelino pour la douzaine de
saisonniers entre petits nouveaux et
habitués tous s'affaire depuis 8 heures
ce matin objectif sélectionner les
meilleurs grappes pour une cuvée de
qualité lorsque j'étais jeune mes
parents étaient viticulteurs et arrivé à
la retraite j'ai décidé de retourner un
petit peu aux sources les premiers jours
ça peut être un peu dur si on n'est pas
trop sportif mais moi je fais du sport
régulièrement donc ça le fait quoi ça le
fait c'est une question faut y aller
quoi il faut avoir envie de le faire
aussi
si le domaine est situé dans le
Vouvrillon les grappes rouges côtoient
les blanches car sur les 12 hectares de
vigne une partie est consacrée à la
production de rosé pétillants et ce
depuis maintenant 30 ans le début de la
gloire
[Rires]
un petit côté poivré dans le raisin un
petit côté framboise qu'on va retrouver
aussi dans le rosé en vaincu à la pause
de midi la première récolte de grelot et
des versets dans la cuve quant au blanc
pour le vouvrer il faudra attendre lundi
le temps pour les grappes de se gorger
de sucre après c'est aussi les
conditions climatiques qui vont qui vont
jouer s'il est beaucoup de pluie sont
annoncé on va accélérer les vendanges
pour sauvegarder ses raisins et pas
qu'il s'abîme et puis si la météo est
plus ensoleillée bon on laissera des
raisins mûrir plus longtemps pour finir
par des moelleux mais ça il y a qu'à la
fin des vendanges on sera c'est parti
pour deux semaines sécateur en main le
tout ponctué de moments de convivialité